india's capital is on red alert
pollution in new delhi has reached
alarming levels raising more health
concerns for the population of 20
million the government is taking drastic
measures in an attempt to curb the
impact it's having on people
this week schools will revert to online
classes construction work has been
banned and government offices will go
remote the city is also considering a
two-day lockdown weather forecast
forecast says winds will not blow from
november 14 to 17 and the smoke from
burning stubble will keep coming to
delhi so the situation could get worse
then
new delhi is one of the most polluted
cities in the world the air is toxic
most of the year and causes more
premature deaths than in any other big
city in the world the air quality has
become especially bad this season as
temperatures dip
the number of farm fires has risen in
neighboring states in the past few weeks
new delhi's government has blamed those
states for not doing enough to solve
what is an annual problem but has come
under fire from the supreme court for
its own ineffective policies
emissions from vehicles industries and
garbage burning remain high and the
government's ban on firecrackers around
the hindu festival of diwali was not
fully enforced
delhi has always had a pollution problem
every year we see bands on firecrackers
during diwali but people defy these the
air quality index in most of the city is
around 500.
it's a big problem we have to wear a
mask all the time so we don't fall sick
we drive all day outside in this dust
our auto rickshaws don't have doors the
government needs to think about us
experts say the government needs to
focus on reducing and monitoring
emissions from major pollutants
including industries cars and
construction sites through the year we
need to develop a ward
village district sub-district state
level
emission inventory for the different
sectors like how much transportation is
contributing how much construction is
contributing from that region
then after that after we need to assign
the responsibility to the people who are
working on the ground or those sectors
the government in new delhi constructed
this mock tower earlier this year after
orders from the supreme court but
experts say measures like these are
largely reactionary and ineffective
given the scale of the crisis while
short-term emergency policies like
lockdowns may ease the problem right now
systemic solutions will require regional
cooperation and political will pavli
mithal al-jazeera new delhi